kenny you have no pictures of the first
half you just wanted to have
conversation yeah a little coffee you've
come to the right place
because everyone's making these moves to
win the championship you look at
you know what brooklyn has done you look
at what the lakers did over last year
you look at
all the movement that's that you look
around the league
my question to the panel
donovan mitchell is at the point
of superstardom where he can take you
there
or he's still all-star status
he needs to be second and third option
really yeah yeah see that yeah he's he's
he has enough talent to do it but what
holds him because see i'm
i'm seeing what i'm saying that he
scores at will
and i'm seeing he's he's overpowering
people yeah he's gonna score what a
superstar is
okay right a superstar the guy who can
win the game multiple ways
true there are a lot of guys who are
great offensive players but a superstar
of a guy who can win a game
if he if he having a bad shoe tonight he
can get a lot of rebounds
or he can play defense uh donald is a
terrific player
he's a foreign machine yeah but that's
that's why he's an all-star ernie
exactly
but i'm saying he doesn't make listen
you know when guys try to
explain this type stuff it seems like
it's old guys hating it's not old guys
hating
it's like okay he's a great scorer i
will give you that but he makes
zero impact on the rest of the game and
and not only that
he's a great scorer i agree with that
but if he's not scoring what else can he
do
i just said that don't repeat after me
yeah but i just had yeah i
the last time he just said it like a
doctor because you said it ebonically i
just had to clear it
and what i wanted to say and i'll end it
here in five seconds because we always
i always say that you know my rule of
being a superstar yeah there's five ways
to accept
uh five or six ways to affect the game
scoring rebound assists
defense leadership pacer game
superstars lead it in three to four
categories
every single night three of those four
uh six categories
all stars two so i'm saying is he
getting to the point where he could be
he's close
well he got to add the second thing like
for me and i'm not complete this is
like i was content like i could win a
game rebounding
i don't have to score i was i could win
a game
rebounded like i wasn't a great defender
but i was content like okay when i got
you controlled the pace of the game too
and they used to throw it inside you
could control them yeah
but that was just to get other guys we
gotta split i'll leave you i'll leave
you with this
in his career one double digit rebound
game one double digit assist game that's
not gonna get it done
okay it's just trying to back up your
point yeah